le camembert l'un des grands symboles de
la normandie fort de son succès ce
fromage attise les convoitises depuis
des défis dans les années 50 le
camembert avait déjà conquis les
américains qui ne se privait pas de le
fabriquer eux mêmes
à l'ouest dans l'état d'ohio une
gigantesque usine fabrique des
commentaires selon des procédés aussi
nettement industriel qu'on peut en
attendre une concurrence internationale
mais aussi nationale qui inquiète
certains producteurs normands soucieux
de préserver leur savoir-faire en 1977
cette fermière dénonce l
industrialisation du camembert et
défendent est la fabrication au lait cru
faire industriel pour défendre leur
terroir et le fromage au lait cru des
producteurs réclament dès les années 80
un label permettant d'identifier le vrai
camembert de normandie il est nécessaire
de bien rentrer spécifique lambert et en
particulier le camembert normand et de
ce fait permettre de ne pas tromper le
consommateur français et étrangers sur
l'origine du produit et sur la qualité
du projet 1983 c'est la reconnaissance
officielle
le camembert d'idées normandie devient
une a aussi une appellation d'origine
contrôlée appellations d'origine
permettra de maintenir ces laiteries qui
risquait de disparaître ce soit une
partie du patrimoine de centres et
relais treize ans plus tard en 1996 la
hausse et devient aop appellation
d'origine protégée propre à l'europe
seuls les camembert au lait cru normand
moulé à la louche et affiné pendant au
moins douze jours peuvent en bénéficier
contrairement aux autres au lait
pasteurisé par exemple un cahier des
charges strict que certains tenteront de
changer en 2007 par exemple le groupe
lactalis réclamait la modification de la
hausse et pour utiliser du lait
pasteurisé à la place du lait cru encore
une fois les défenseurs du vrai
camembert font bloc
le camembert c'est aussi un phénomène
que touristico culturel c'est un peu
l'image de la france et des français
après avoir été celui de la normandie un
emblème un emblème donc on touche pas
aux anglais après plusieurs années de
résistance
l'institut national de l'origine et de
la qualité cédera finalement en février
un accord de principe et conclue avec
les industriels laitiers visant à
élargir la op au camembert pasteurisé
d'ici 2021
une décision qui passe mal auprès des
militants du lait cru la guerre du
camembert continue
[Musique]